this episode of fun science is brought
to you by Skillshare you friend me
whatever you doing up so late looks like
you might need a lesson in the
importance of a good night's sleep in
this episode of yeah if you're lucky
enough to live until you're 90 chances
are you would have spent about 30 years
of your life asleep which is crazy when
you consider that scientists are still
yet to agree on exactly why our bodies
tempt us into bed every night but we do
know about sleep however is just how
important it really is now it used to be
thought that when you went to sleep your
body just sort of turned off tonight but
of course if our bodies did just turn
off like this we'd all be quite dead
what we know now is that it's more like
your body gets dialed down our breathing
slows our heart rate lowers and the
muscles in our body relax
we even experience a decrease in body
temperature this is when we enter the
stage of sleep known as slow wave or
deep sleep during which our bodies do
some amazing things like preparing
themselves and releasing growth hormones
all of which is essential for our health
in fact some studies have shown that
sleep is as essential to our health as
food with sleep deprivation being as
dangerous as starvation obviously this
is bad news for those of us who suffer
from sleeping difficulties now
fortunately if you do have trouble
getting a good night's sleep cognitive
behavioral therapy or CBT might help as
it's been shown to reduce these issues
by 50% on average so we know how
important sleep is for our bodies
about our brains well when we sleep it
gives our brains time to take stock of
all the stimuli we've been subjected to
throughout the day the name of the cute
barista that smiled at you today gone
with a healthy seven to eight hours each
night our mind can sort through all this
information committing the useful stuff
to memory and checking the bits we don't
need the humiliating feeling you got
when you accidentally misgendered one of
your coworkers we're going to hold onto
this one forever after slow-wave you
enter the deepest part of the sleep
cycle known as rapid eye movement or REM
sleep during which our brains actually
show as much activity as when we're
awake REM sleep is also when we have
some of our most vivid dreams why we
dream could still a mystery to science
but what we do know is that this is also
when we enter sleep paralysis which
stops us removing our bodies thus
helping prevent us from acting out our
dreams in real life did I make you yawn
you know it used to be thought that
yawning was a way of bringing more
oxygen into the body at times when our
breathing explodes but now researchers
suggesting that as we get more tired the
temperature regulations of our brain
don't function as efficiently and so to
combat this our body forces us to bring
in a deep breath of nice cool air
one theory behind why yawns are
contagious is that based on evolution it
would make sense for groups to be able
to coordinate times of activity and rest
so next time you're up past your bedtime
don't forget just how important a good
night's sleep is for your body and your
brain sleep tight
though if you do have trouble sleeping
did you know that there's a skill show
course for that
in fact as well as courses like this one
on how to get a better night's sleep
Skillshare which is an online learning
community has loads of other courses to
check out on topics like lifestyle and
creativity and if you're one of the
first 500 people who sign up using the
link in the description you'll get your
first two months for free giving you
access to all of the courses on
Skillshare so go and learn or go and
sleep and thanks for watching bye bye